お家の片付けしてた
こんにちははじめ社長ですとより年ぶりやってまいりましたあー謎んで買った真の
抜き打ち調査
この動画では僕のアマゾンの方履歴過去2年間分を全部見るというやつなんですけども
過去2回やってますね4年前の僕の甘酢の空気で歴2年前のあのちょっとこぎりそして
それから今までの2年間はまずの攻撃で今日今から見るわけなんですけども
ん
うーんそうねあの
まあ今年はちょっと自粛オーチーにことも多くてなんかこうね皆無の日もいけなかった
から結構たくさん amazon で買ったんですけど誰か何買ったか覚えてないの
いろいろ買いすぎてて基本 amazon で買ってるからそれこわい本当に何か金
取るとかアマゾン免除とかも使ってるから本当にも自分で何を買ったか覚えてないけど
なんかエロい漫画とか勝手なきます
古賀も包み隠さず自分を見ていこうと思いますあの勘違いされたら嫌なんですけど俺
そんななんか真面目でいいやつないからね普通に萌えを大好きですからそれは今が多分
あのわかると思うんです
[音楽]
とりあえず見ていきましょうどうぞ
はい時に見ていけません2018年の5月2018年の5月の中旬以降か見ていき
ましょう
これの邪眼のマンガにはまった頃でまああのなんか服とか靴も結構 amazon で
買っちゃうんですよってこのスモークとかも動画ようですね
このエアーサーファーも動画で釣っ使ったやつここでまともですね世界1位のスーパー
超激辛唐辛子買ってますねああ
ここなんか夏の企画で使うと思ったんですけどこういうのを買ってますと
サーキュレーター
いい
タッチペンあっそうだとか言ってたのかなスプレー
チョークですねスプレー方がもうていき見てますねここでグラ盛り懸垂マシーン猫背の
歌猫背の歌でなんか猫背系のグッズがとかってなんかパソコンで使ったり何だろうなに
これ今なかったがあるっていう中根公然にはまっている
握力計買って iphone 買ってた爺さんの1/7スケールで使って黒い
人形を買ってて5歩の絵を爆買しましたこれ畑用で使ってやつから一週間に十日休みた
いっていうツアー取れば高いほどかぶりやすい t シャツ
センスあるね中高センサーで買い物してますねいや割とまともかは国家遊戯王カード
買ったり三脚買ってドラゴンボールがすごかったり
だー使ったりな何度見てパズあるもうさでも理解ヒロ赤の一番お買い上げを自分で尺
世界最強ので者が勝手につなぎもこれ動画で使ったやつだね
意外とまともか缶バッチ買ってこれんだもどうか関係なんてほとんどデートダーリンな
フランキーの zero ii にすごいハマっちゃって買っていましたね
巨大号リング寺など
をで買ってる難しいここまだーりんザランキスの8アニメをめっちゃ
[音楽]
申しますよ
ああああああ
うーん漫画なんですけど
村人島の一手がいるんですけどめちゃくちゃ a 6艇女の人が来たらをとりあえずの
襲っちゃえみたいなそういう島に暮らすが漂流しちゃってもうあれやこれやと思う
松技
ねはい楽しかったですて iphone ケースなボールに向かって畑系のモードの
引っかかってるんでここらへん
ないと買ったり太鼓買ったりは受けかと結構はポケカね
ポケカか2世で結構けっこうこれ動画で見たことない奴多いんじゃないでしょうか
遊戯王あっあったりから見て焼いてねしっかりカメラも買ってますよ
すればしてますねテンガーロボ買って来ずなりちゃんのぬいぐるみ3市で買ってでまだ
ポケカポケカポケット2年前だからちょっとおり記憶が自分でコバラサポートの肇社長
9月ような10個が今実ログ絶賛幸と海がすごく5年で端から集ってますねはいもう
基本はちょっと出たくない人なんです口とかもかっつんですがまとめてここらへんなん
でしょうどショップ館カード
ですね issei 使ってるねあと人をダメにするソファーとかこたつ俺に勝って
ますね
セーターを買いたくなったんだろうなこれでどんどんフレーズハロいいねことキロはつ
いいところへ行ったらホラーの波が切手でまたポケカに戻ります g マイロンなんで
俺
どんとぷりーずこんな短期間でネコ飼ってるんだ何裏買ってお電話を電脳ネイキッ
ネクタイを叩きより可愛いハーロックの衣装ですねまたペッカーもうなんか変な時計の
このおしゃれな家具買いたくなって効果ありますよねこっからでヒロは神だして地区内
懐くのそうキーって買ってますねヘアドライヤーを激安にして
の20個動画です動画で使っていると思いました
また服を剥いゲームボーイ見てを購入またゲームおよびかかって旅游行母でございます
まあこれは東京の東京の良い栄養に勝てるヤツですねこのソファーとかあっていうよう
な関係の特徴4枚付とかいます
悪縁の市販車とは点すら突然訂正等の7歩み出している
どうしちゃったんだろうれ遊行のカイザー久保氏はもう1回フラダリラボ4枚は
キミキセって味でも木暮ながまた目指している
ますね去年の yt へーとかな youtube 3節の空の
何か必要なのかんってアクアドルフィン向こうで会連合エネルギーマット
ポケカ
があって来てねバンボレロ先輩はバニーガールこれ真面目ですねチョコを買ってずっと
ここらへんはずっと青春部0にはまって3つ見てますね
柿の種を迎えますうーんあとデスク折りたたみ椅子後席の国にハマってますねここ2年
前の年末はないか
宝石の国見てたからねこれこれが2018年でしたあぶねーあぶねー
まあ淫語字幕ライフ危なかったのはめっちゃエロいですよねもお勧めですはい行きまし
た2019年見ていきましょう
まあ
iphone ケース官はドラまあこの辺まで遊戯王ですね
バッチバチに遊戯を買ってますねやっぱり今販売されていないカードでも数しかない
から謎でどうぞを買っちゃいますねすげーなく急にプロテクター回出しましたね
食用の銀峯海ドラを買ってますでまた遊戯王大革命がい紹介体育マットを買ってます
ドラの凡愚ペリエ気にターンサービスにハマってる
ここらへんもずっと宝石の国がめちゃくちゃな映画綺麗な始めますの宝石の国女の子か
な
女の子と結構好きそぉ来たらもの汗でもすごい楽しかったです女性をエプロン動画用に
開放的な国をずっと見ながらまあこれも動画ようですね撤回一言動画撮ったりして
にこれストレス解消立体アートクローンなにやってんの俺多いないんだけどこんなので
サプライズリング
巨大の動画でも使ってやつですねスタンドミラーをたくさん買ってますね光を反射する
やつ
ギリースーツの車も買ってます防毒マスク化学防護服も買ってますねまた店さんで
ミスミソウってこれまでなんかホラーの映画で怖かったんですよ
戦闘機デイちゃん飼ってるんですうわぁ1枚5万3000なぜこれでここもずっと
小型店ステイするはまって
な方法でカメラ競馬と書くと水アロラベトベターロブというのカメラを止めるのは見て
ますここで農薬マスク俺って何をしてたんだってか質疑 wi-fi 掃除機個ぐらい
も東京用のあるです
きっとあのシャーペンも限定品のが出ると張って買っちゃうんですよねベイベーどっか
いい
寝ながらメディキュット買ってます足当てした時期があって
バッグ b カットここなさんのあばれる君2枚買ってるねデスノート買ってポケモン
のサトシハト市のコスメ tenga の方が可哀想だって友達を2匹飼ってこれ
超電磁砲かなルールが見てますね
でカメラ買ってグローブ長すぎ
買って言語間で
すげー向かってどうして俺ここらへん距離格闘技いい館でちゃってるけど匂い
チェッカー
バッテリーアニメの木村星図を食べたい方で3つ始めましたね
俺またお酢で今回結構まっとうな解法のしかし水ビーズクッション扇風機
5月ながらちょっと暑くなってきたのはね英霊が7敗でも2を見ています大田区いいと
エライエライぞれ
ポケカもしっかり開封ために買ってますねリスタートのチェック3枚かえらいぞお偉い
ぞ
的のかなにこれもうちょっと切れなければコラボしただから何を見ないとと
てっきりたちを見ていますテクニックに小動物をたくさんあってソニーのボイス
レコーダー買ってメール参加でジョイこの右側だけ買って何飛び交います
焼肉グリルこれまで5日動画で使うと思ってるんですけどまだ使えてないんですよね
でっか利下げの花を買ったんですよトミックさあを海に突き落として海のそこにいた女
の顔でてるっていうドッキリしようとしたんですけど今だにできている
です二と僅差の顔編キング買いましたギャザマジックザギャザリングここでちょっと
やろうと思った時期がありますよね
ですもんかイイネそっくりの中に見終わったり
リリーちゃんドロー会杯ではなんか構ってまた買ってますね2回見てるレンタルかな
から会場図の高木さんも見てますねまた友情か
まとまとまとオリコンがまとめをそっくりの犬だらけにしてめっちゃいなかった時
でしょうと思ったんですけどなんかつまんなくて大倉にしてプレゼントもったいなかっ
たな
竹とんぼあールーザー崖っぷちモデル地獄
女かおもろかったです
音が女同士のモデルの争いというか結構楽しかったですね忙しい人線を作りを偽色ど
なんだ料理に目覚めだした変わってくらあ
バナナ t シャツなにこれガルパンのここまでとかっていうまぁここらへんあんまり
記憶ないなこれ
俺+マ中でなんて買ったっけ誰かやってる混ぜ記憶ないんだけどこれ
まあそう52号室
だったらまずで覚えてないでよる今なかったっけなぜここへね5等分の花よねあまり
ましたねポッピンアラジンっていう照明器具なんですけどプロジェクターになってるん
ですよめっちゃを入れておりませんでしょバスタオル
またポケカさてポケモン騒動ここで買ってます遠くなるネーム作りでここで決めつの刃
の何が取っておきますね多分アニメの先が気になっちゃって読んじゃったパターンです
ねこれああっを譲って zero ii のフィギュアを買いアナベルをここで見て
ます d がめっちゃ怖かったですゼロスーツサムスの個室よ
友人に話して
また違っという行カードが切ってますねこれも結局何かどうか関係かな
たまにダイエットサプリとかもちょっとね変なとこで美容に興味があるんですよ
高嶺の花なサンゴ a
いいマンなんですよ花さんてもなるとかすごいツンツンしてるんですけど可愛らしい
ちゃう
いい漫画でしまっ鈴型アップデーぽつプロもここで買ってますねハンガー a オレ
マットもちゃう効果や
君のいる町はい君のいる町はなんか昔ようなんですけどもう1校で読み直してますね
いや君の街までめっちゃいい漫画なんですよしっかり作って待っています
[音楽]
かなみ盛りっていうマンのは本当にただただエロいままですねあ謎
なんていいでしょ
まだその声援に目覚めてない高校生どうしてかなちょっと興味本意で
4つんやろう
b サーズのがちゃんと買って8 pot 進撃の巨人も35歳心眼で
[音楽]
鎧袖一触っていう漫画もいい
エロい漫画なんですよ
では俺エロ漫画芸人山も鎧袖一触はなんか真ん中の女の子がその
引っ越す家がなくて不動産の仲介の仕事してる主人公の男の人の家に泊まることになっ
ちゃったんですよねそのいろいろある中でさやっぱ男女が歳ですぐといろいろあるわけ
ですよ
それかもうねっ
墨鬼エロい非常に僕の好みの良さでしたねこれよはすごいたんですよね
どうするのかの方がいい
この動画どうするのは基本ではまたもでしょ
あ速さで同じにプンプン買ってるおやすみぷーんお兄漫画でしたねすごい
闇を感じる漫画だった2010時期んですけど大熱波で
を張っておりますゆかのいやーどうにかここまでマート事言えないでしょ
まともとは言えないけどまぁそんななんか傘めちゃな官能的なベロなあというふうに何
かちょっと正統派ん
制度派とかわかんですけど
比較的なこそ品等でもなんかな御坂には良かった
いや何かそういう漫画に行くないですかはいで見ていきましょう2020年ですまず
ふっピンの1年だったので腹筋グッズからせまで来れなく届かないから1回超巨大な一
打目にすると私ピンピンしたんですよねミーハーな最初の3つ
東京番地リベンジャーズ波がここできたとめっちゃくそ
そのか+映画化ももうすぐすると思うんですけどすごい楽しみで妻やパンツのここで
選んでますね
アービング社の新刊が感じてるんでこうでしっかりとつなぎ合って
度か悩みを読みつつ彼の増加にしますが
2002順でも最初の方でバッチリはまりましたねカメラがチトフウカンってきてまた
一緒時間ってやけ端に動いロスつパソコン枚の
記号ここ粘って勝ってるかな
やばい娘の友達っていう漫画がありまして
あの難点でしょうお父さんが主人公なんですけどを登山の娘で薄めがちょっと不登校に
なっちゃってるんですけどもお父さんがその会社でも圧かけられたり娘は不登校で学校
からつかけられたりでちょっとかもう嫌だってなっているときにその娘の友達の女の子
にシボ優しくされちゃってもそりゃもう
大変なことになる漫画ですうーん
楽しかったですいい行きまーぬーキャンプっ
オールステッカー鏡カペッロ僧侶系あっちゃーレマンぬーさんかっ飛ばすとパティ
2の人民の考えられないような開放路線のスケルトンっていうとアーク約残す2を買っ
たりしますねっラジコンヘリエディターにこれもなんかほら笑顔なねーかで定期的に見
たくなっちゃうんですよ
でこれさあこのオックスフォードなんか超なんとかって書いてあるんですけど覚えて
ない気がすんだよなんかよくわかんなくて結局外側ができるしまいます
でここらへんからも寿司口に入ってるんでたぶんなんかねおうちで見れる系っていうか
マンガと映画区でエピソー
まずこれもほら映画ですねハローワールドで根底ゾーン動画にましたんですけどすごい
コロナが悪化し過ぎたらっていう世界で
感が出ている
[音楽]
また来てますね不信感でたんで買いましたニルヴァー紹介暗さかなぁここで筋トレ分目
がガーッと聞いてますねえ b スタート最新刊ポケカもありますはいでここでドラマ
の合図っていうねはまってみましたねの時間ができたんですよ
お家に居る時間すごいできたからアニメじゃなくてなんかドラマとかも見れるなと思っ
て会津ってドラマ見たら本当に面白かったです
3つおすすめ
にドイツ人尺のエデンも見つつ彼女を借りしますのかの彼の最初を見つつ会津全部みっ
て
で呪文見てるねここでこんな感じですねー
meets ボルダーという筋トレ系がすごいですこれ
食品サンプルの動画のためにめざ草サンプル勝手でですねゲーミングキーボード手間と
いう行神龍巨人最新刊はしっかり抑えていきます
この2グラム時計買ったりあとこれも動画の曲で使うと思ったんだけどたらシール
たくさん買ったといまだにできてない何かモノを買ったけどやってね結構多いんですよ
ねもっと面白くでき
ないからこのハロウィンのねゾンビのしたい8耐買ったんですけども使ってないですね
を打ち出す別なを買いまくりましたたら定期にマニューラさっきも勝てなかったっけ州
中マイロの上流
ポケモンのタイプ相性の動画でストロング官がこのようからなくなるという噂を聞いて
めっちゃかっとけペン河童ここで映像県映像顕如だなぁ
耳にはまってちょっと見てました分ら箇所10個やろうとしてるんだね
でジオラマ自宅にズっていることが多くて上欄にはまりました
クロコダイルのって強裏負けここで急に吠え出して左利きのエロ漫画で見てぶーミラー
がたんまりなと思ってめちゃくちゃここでブームの会始めます
あっ
t とか色々あって雲の手を取ってますよね日焼け止めのオークスで買ったり花の会で
最新は遊戯王の漫画映画でて又雪を見て50回目のファーストキスて映画が本当にね見
たら泣きます
よかったです
またいう行ババア見て信じる93人には座技リティっていうこれもすごい
海外の映画なんですけど方であ娘の友達の4巻と5巻が出てるんでみました
ドメスティックな彼女をここでパッと見始めてますねこれ俺の番がのシッコやばいな
多分なんかちょっと現実にはありえないようだね堂々した話し方が好きなんですよね
つっぱり母校で買っていく
これに結構も最近ですねはピッチャーがすごい好きでピッチもカットリー
g 糖質ゼロ免買ってちょっと痩せようと思います機密な刃の仲良しうここで小と思っ
てまた
フレイヤ強めますねあとぴっ2回まくってますカートに入っちゃってるな
やばいやばいこれはちょっと待ってもらった
オレはー
ちょっそうだねえ今日日本ですねこれじゃだめ強力です
あのストーリーは良かったで出演2たくさん買ってがクランクアップ
チェーンソーマンここでまた見出してますねまだ乳業カード見て
また動画にしてないね黙れところあるんでとレーザーここまでで許してください
うわっいやあの
[音楽]
弁解の余地はないですねー待ってこんなこんなもんでしょは男って男って女ばでしょ
う2
また2年後
[音楽]
ん